I love a salmon during the holidays.
It's like a little unexpected.
So this is a really, really easy recipe.
You're basically gonna take your little whisk here.
This is some honey, some Dijon mustard,
a couple little spices in there.
And you're just gonna mix it all up.
I love honey.
And what it's gonna do in the air fryer
is it's gonna kind of caramelize
and make it a little thicker
so it's gonna stay in place
versus like running off of the salmon.
Yes.
So we'll take our salmon
and we'll just put it right in there.
And it's gonna coat all over it.
If you wanna get real crazy,
you can leave it in like a marinade
but you really don't have to.
The trick with the salmon is parchment paper.
And it's one thing I really love to use
with this recipe
because have you ever cooked salmon
and then the skin comes off on the pan?
And you're like oh, this looks like a mess.
The parchment paper will save your skin
and you'll get that beautiful like crispy skin
on the bottom,
which also makes it easier
when you're serving it to everybody.
So preheating your air fryer a couple minutes.
This is nice and warm now.
We're gonna take it out.
Okay, so this is gonna just lay right into the bottom,
and then you're gonna just put your salmon on top,
skin side down.
And I do like to keep a little of the sauce
on the side that has not been contaminated
with your raw salmon.
So afterwards, you can add some extra sauce
if you like things a little bit saucy.
I'm gonna put that in.
And depending on the size of your salmon,
like six to seven minutes.
You don't wanna go too crazy
'cause then it'll be really dry.
(upbeat music)